quand il a appris la nouvelle le maire
de cruzy le châtel a sauté de joie
le château de maulnes loto du patrimoine
une belle opportunité pour la commune se
retrouver à voir les tickets virée à
gratter ou en voir notre château à cruzy
le châtel on s'est quand même quelque
chose de viread de diass et exclusif
c'est vraiment une grande une grande
chance et pour le territoire et pour le
village puisque on va parler on va
parler du village et surtout on va
récupérer des fonds pour terminer cette
bâtisse édifiée au xvième siècle pour la
comtesse de tonnerre ce château
pentagonale est aujourd'hui classé
monument historique
claude le gardien du château le connaît
par coeur une des particularités de ce
château et année un puits central
entouré d'un escalier
ce puits nous permettait d'alimenter
tous les étages en eau et en même temps
et nous alimenté par la lumière en eau
laissé à l'abandon au cours du 19ème
siècle le château a beaucoup souffert
il faut attendre 1997 pour que le
département de l'yonne nouveau
propriétaire décide de le restaurer mais
en 2016 faute de budget les travaux
s'arrêtent
la collectivité a besoin d'un million
d'euros pour reprendre le chantier les
deux tiers de la toiture et des façades
sont ont été faites
il reste encore deux façades a terminé
ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui c'est que
grâce à cette opération loto du
patrimoine on puisse recommencer le
chantier et le terminer et pour la
sauvegarde du bâtiment complet après
bussy rabutin l'an dernier le château de
môle ne sera le deuxième monument
bourguignon a figuré sur les tickets à
gratter
en plus d'être sauvé il pourrait attirer
des milliers de visiteurs
supplémentaires